my top time management tips are calendar
everything use your calendar in a very
active way everything goes in there that
is at least remotely time bound so for
example the doctor says that she wants
to see you again in a year and she gives
you a little blood test requisition form
this can become three calendar entries
right obviously the doctor's appointment
a year from now but then call the lab
find out how long it's going to take
them to process the lab collection so
that it can get to the doctor in time
and the map becomes a calendar entry
when you have to go to the lab and then
figure out how long in advance you can
call the lab for an appointment to drop
in
that's the third entry now you're
leaving nothing to chance
and I want to emphasize I'm not talking
about organizing your time to the point
that you become a Spock like automaton
or Lieutenant Commander data automaton
the idea is that if you don't have to
think about things like this you're
freeing up neural resources that you can
dedicate to the things you really care
about a lot of people over schedule
they're more ambitious in what they
think they'll get done then they really
can and so on the fly as things pop up
they'll say oh well I can't really do
that now or I'm not gonna do that now
and what I advocate is being more
deliberate about this you choose what it
is that are gonna be your priorities and
the way that I recommend is to get index
cards and put one task on each card and
then you can reorganize them throughout
the day you you can put this one here
and this one here and the beauty of this
is that once you've prioritized
everything that you have to do
whatever's on that top card that's the
thing that is the most important thing
you should be doing and so you find that
your mind doesn't wander you're more
efficient and productive because you're
really focused on that now that most
important thing might not even be you
know complete the complete the Penske
file it might be you know work on the
Penske file for an hour and a half today
and then go to the second card right but
it allows you to control your workflow
and and not just workflow but your
social time your errands your leisure
time your
those all go in the stack too it allows
you to control them rather than the
environment controlling you there's this
theory in economics behavioral economics
called hyperbolic discounting and it has
to do with the way we see future events
and it applies to the way we schedule
our time if somebody asks you to do
something a year from now you think oh
that's that's that's so long from now
and I got nothing else on my calendar
sure I'll do it but then you know you're
from now you're probably going to be
just as busy and overstretched
and stressed out as you are today so you
haven't really realized that you've
discounted the impact of it
it's called hyperbolic because of the
shape of the mathematical function I
think the idea is it's important to say
no to things that you really don't want
to do and to allow yourself time every
day for spontaneity and creativity and
doing things that you really care about
if you don't get a little of that each
day you wake up one morning and you
realize it for six months you've just
been slogging and nothing enjoyable has
happened
you